Why can gluten be an issue for a cancer patient?
So gluten, remember, gluten is what is found in wheat.
It's the protein in wheat, rye, spelt, malt, barley.
And rye added is actually the protein.
And you could have sensitivities to it.
So gluten can be inflammatory.
So even if you don't have sensitivities,
I mean, antibodies to gluten or one of its part, you know,
particles of gluten, which are called peptides of a protein.
You don't have antibodies against gluten as an entire molecule
or its peptides.
It still could be inflammatory.
So it can cause anything that can cause inflammation in your body
or inflammation in your gut can hinder your immune system's ability
to do other things, in this case, or a cancer patient to kill cancer cells.
Is it a good idea for cancer patients to go gluten free?
Maybe that would be an extension of this.
Yeah, that would be a good idea.
Is it necessary?
Is gluten ever feeding the cancer?
Typically no.
Gluten is not going to be a feeder of a cancer, a specific
gliadid as a protein.
It's certainly the peptides of gliadid.
And it's not going to be a fuel source for cancer.
But can gluten cause issues with certain cancer patients more than others?
Yes.
Especially if you have antibodies against gliander,
it's peptides you're going to have more inflammation,
and it's going to cause more of an issue for a person.
So I will not say that gluten is always going to cause an issue for a cancer patient
and every cancer patient should go off with gluten.
But you should at least consider, you know,
when you're trying to deal with cancer,
sometimes it's easy to ignore other comorbidities
that maybe even preceded the diagnosis of cancer.
A.K.A. would be maybe gut issues and maybe food sensitivities
that you never really knew that you had,
nor did you address prior to your diagnosis of cancer.
And could have actually been a piece of the puzzle
that broke down your immune system that was a piece of the cause
of why a person got cancer in the first place.
They had other ill health.
In this case, gut inflammation that, you know,
helped contribute to a worse diagnosis.
So it's never wise to just ignore other health issues
just trying to quote unquote treat or kill cancer.
You have to do a more holistic approach
and try to get your whole self more healthy.
That's why with all our cancer patients,
we also address gut health.
And that is important because your detoxification pathways,
your gut health, your overall whole body health,
is equally important in order for you to listen to proper immune response
to kill cancer.
So it's all a piece of that.
So why can gluten be an issue for a cancer patient?
All those reasons.
Anything that can cause inflammation is going to decrease your ability
to fight an immune elicited immune response to kill cancer.